LORIN PRICE: Hey, Brian.
I heard we're demoing
BigQuery GIS today.
What exactly will
we be looking at?
BRIAN SUK: Well, Lauren,
you're absolutely right.
So today I will be using public
data from the US Census and New
York City Taxi and
Limousine Commission
to help us analyze
data in different ways
so that users can make
more informed decisions.
For example, we can look
at population hotspots
to see where it might make
sense to place stores.
LORIN PRICE: Sounds very cool.
And can you talk about
the feature updates
made to BigQuery to allow
for these new GIS features?
BRIAN SUK: Yeah, absolutely.
So the BigQuery GIS team has
partnered with the Google Earth
Engine team to integrate
geospatial data types
and functions into BigQuery.
A lightweight
visualization tool called
BigQuery Geo Viz has
also been created
for users who want to
quickly plot and style
their geospatial query
results on a map for analysis.
LORIN PRICE: Let's take a look.
BRIAN SUK: So I'm
a retailer looking
to open up a new store
within New York City.
Specifically, I'm looking at
this particular neighborhood
around the point
that's shown here.
If I want to gauge how
successful my store is going
to be, there's certain questions
that I want to ask around
that point, things
such as are there
are a lot of people who
happen to live around there?
And is there a lot of taxi and
foot traffic around that point?
Now with the standard
dimensional modeling,
these are questions that are
not necessarily easy to answer.
However, this is where
geospatial analysis
is perfectly suited.
The first query I'm going
to load up is a simple one.
This one is quite simply asking
the data set how many people
live within 1,000
meters of that point
that we were showing earlier.
Now when I run
this query, you're
going to see that
according to the US Census,
it's stating that there's
113,734 people who
live around that point.
But what makes it so easy
is this particular section
within the WHERE clause.
There's two things I
want to point out there.
The first one is this
particular data type here.
With BigQuery Geospatial
Information Services,
we introduced new
geography data types,
which makes things such as
polygons and points on a map
easy to represent
within a query.
And there are a number
of different functions,
such as the ST distance within
function we're using here,
which makes it very
easy to represent
those kinds of questions.
So instead of trying to finagle
a lot of different joins
and a lot of different ways
to query this information,
we can now simply
just ask it, within
this particular
geopoint, how many people
live within 1,000 meters of it.
So let's take this use
case a little bit further.
Before, we were analyzing
one specific store
and we were trying
to do a simple query.
But what if we want to
look at more stores?
What I have set up here
are five different stores
within the city of
New York, and they're
going to be represented
by coordinates.
Each one of these I want to link
up with both the census data,
but I also want to merge it with
the New York City taxicab data.
Now this is a
public data set that
is hosted on Google's
BigQuery in partnership
with the New York City Taxi
and Limousine Commission.
And part of this
information also
provides, for certain years,
longitude and latitude
coordinate information for
where taxes are dropped off.
And so now what I
can do is merge this
all together and not only
get population information,
but I can also figure out how
many people are being dropped
off within 100 meters
of each of my stores,
the idea being if
I have people who
are going to be
frequenting that area
or being dropped off constantly,
maybe they can see my store,
make an impulse buy,
or drop in on the way
there on to where
they're originally going.
So if I run this
query, now I have
points on a map, which I can
place for each of my five
stores, the population counts
within 1,000 meters of it,
and I can also have a 100-meter
radius count of the taxis that
are dropped off there.
So if I map this
out and I tell it
that these are
the points I want,
here are my five
different stores.
I can now add visual cues
to indicate how many people
are going to live around that.
So let's put some
data ranges on it.
And so now I have circles
of different sizes
around my points,
which are telling me
how many people live around it.
And maybe I want to
change the color of each
of these different
circles to tell me,
using the taxi count, how many
people are being dropped off
in a year around
each of these points.
So let's give these
different colors,
going from blue to the
lowest all the way up to red
as the most.
And interestingly,
what this is telling me
is that the area with the
lowest population around one
of my stores happens to have the
highest volume of taxi dropoffs
within a 100-meter radius.
And this is information
I can quickly
determine using visual analysis
and geospatial analysis
to make better
business decisions,
and hopefully make future
decisions much more efficiently
on where to place other stores.
LORIN PRICE: So there
you have it, folks.
Brian was easily able
to use geospatial data
types in BigQuery GIS to query
information about population
at an exact longitude
and latitude location
BRIAN SUK: Yep.
And I was also able to
plot multiple points
on a map in the
BigQuery Geo Viz tool,
and layered in population
and New York City taxicab
data that can now be used to
influence business decisions
for retail store owners.
LORIN PRICE: If you have a
cool project you're working on,
let us know.
The link for that's
in the description.
BRIAN SUK: And also, don't
forget to like the video,
leave a comment, and
subscribe to the channel.
LORIN PRICE: Thanks
for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]